I literally was just on my phone and
that this story popped up about your dad
defending you angry angry mean bullies
online how do you respond to that and
how do you handle that kind of hate I
mean it definitely hurts when you see
stuff like that and but it doesn't
matter at the end of the day like they
don't know you and they're just people
trying to spread their negativity here
and you just have to kind of separate it
from your real life because it's truly
just like this whole other world of just
people with anonymous cloaks it can
seriously affect you a specific person
that I use as an example or my dad and I
both posted like said he wanted me dead
which is like I'm it's like no one wants
to hear that obviously and like he
doesn't know me I've never met him I
doubt he's ever seen my work if he has
whatever you just have to remember like
it's just a stranger online going off
and trying to spread their negativity
but you have to keep separate and use
that as inspiration to spread even more
positivity and and not positive change
in the world since there are so many
people being negative any advice for
anyone going through that right now yes
absolutely I would just say I know it
and I know it can hurt and I know it can
really get you down or get to you but
you just have to be yourself and stay
true to what you know and stay true to
who you are because you're fantastic the
way you are and you can't let anybody
mean you of your worth like you've been
brought up in this industry obviously
your dad is Kevin Smith what do they
need the best piece of advice that he's
given you um I would say that the best
piece of advice is probably just no
matter what anyone's job is on a setter
and
treat everybody with equal amount of
respect correct me if I'm wrong but I
feel like you were named after harley
quinn from you were ok so have you seen
suicide squads yes i have seen it I
don't even know how many times now it is
a fantastic movie i'll stand by that
movie till the day i die i love it so
much if you love harley quinn like you
feel a special connection to her oh my
god absolutely i feel such a strong
connection to with her not only because
we share a name but margot robbie did a
fantastic amazing job or trying her and
I could not be happier with the
performance she gave Ida school like I
feel such a special connection I heard
that there's gonna be some spin-off
movies there in the works possibly it's
rumored what do we do to get you a cameo
anything i would love nobody i'm just in
the corner like eating some food or
something or literally anything that
would mean the world we gotta have
someone like make a call put in that s
when i'm gonna be like on my agent
begging her like you gotta get me into
this somehow